this place may now look like a golf
course but it was once Amazonian jungle
alta floresta is located in the state of
mato grosso in the center of Brazil
decades of deforestation have made this
a profitable area for agribusiness and
that's why the recent fire is affecting
the Amazons are not surprising to people
like Bruno dos Santos every year there
are fires but the situation is worse now
because of climate change and the
president he basically tells people to
go and cut down trees and nothing will
happen to them the data we have here
shows the heat and it can be verified
whether it's a fire he compares the maps
of 2018 with what is happening this year
millions of trees gone with the help of
seesaws and fire the map shows us where
the fires are we travel for four hours
and arrive at one of the places it
highlighted in parts of the Amazon the
burned areas have increased by 83
percent in just the past year
fires are natural at this time of the
year because of the dry weather the heat
and the wind but environmentally say
that the sharp increase seen this year
is due to farmers setting the forest
alight to clear the land for pastures
the problem is that in many cases those
fires get out of control Brazilian law
says that landowners can only cut down
20% of the trees in their property but
that's rarely enforced Carlos not his
real name is a small farmer in the area
he's afraid to show his face
presidential war zone arrow has
repeatedly said he wants to open up the
Amazons for business Carlos says that
has encouraged people to burn more trees
there are no controls nobody is watching
what people are doing both soon our Dahl
says he wants development and this is
what development may bring there is no
limits to ambition and everyone wants
more
deeper in the forest it's not difficult
to find cut down trees hidden in the
woods hiding from the satellites it's
the first step to conquer New
Territories and extend the agricultural
frontier for cattle and crops the
government insist the situation is no
worse than previous years but satellite
imagery shows something different and
that's why countries like Germany and
Norway have halted all payments to the
Amazon fund accusing the government of
failing to protect the environment
planet FRES has lived in this area his
whole life he has been struggling to
find a middle ground between
preservation and development the
simplistic speech of the president that
he is attacking NGOs he is attacking
families from here they want to take
resources from NGOs because we published
the truth he says we are attacking the
country we can all work together for
preservation and development somebody
needs to explain to the government we
are not the enemy government control is
the only way to prevent the destruction
of what is left of Amazonia but what
worries many here is that they claim the
central government is purposely looking
away terasawa
al jazeera alta floresta mato grosso